nevertheless important regards Ed
Sheeran and that case that uh where he's
been accused of plagiarizing Marvin
Gaye's Let's Get It On Let's cross to
Washington and uh U.S correspondent
James Matthews so what is happening in
that case James
thanks very much indeed Mark yeah good
news for Ed Sheeran he has won that case
a jury in New York has decided that he
did not infringe copyright he did not
steal the musical building blocks of the
Marvin Gaye classic Let's Get It On the
Case have been brought by the co-writers
of that Marvin Gaye tune they said that
the key elements of the Rhythm and
Melody not the whole song but the
building blocks of that song were the
same as the Marvin Gaye classic that
Thinking Out Loud had the same structure
essentially the same musical structure
as the Marvin Gaye song and they
were Julie suing Ed Sheeran there would
have been a damages hearing later on to
decide how much he would have paid for
that but the jury has sided with the
British Artist he had gone to court
claiming that this was insulting he said
that most pop songs could be put on top
of most other pop songs he says for
example Let It Be can segue into No
Woman No Cry there is a basic for chord
progression on which multiple songs are
based and his lawyers had argued that
um you know these were the letters of
the alphabet in music and if you were to
decide that there was a copyright
infringement in this case that would
have a wide-ranging impact on the rest
of music as we know it so that was the
argument for the Sheeran side of this
case he took his guitar into court there
was a a live music defense by Ed Sheeran
the music in the in the witness box
playing some of the key cards in that
tune thinking out loud and he was
demonstrating why there was a difference
in the chords that were used so
ultimately it's good news for the Music
musician good news for his fans as well
I might say he did say in this court
case that if he lost that he would be
done the clear implication that his
musical career would be at an end so
that clearly isn't a scenario anybody's
looking uh no Ed Sheeran just throw my
jamark has won that case in New York a
jury has decided that he is not guilty
of copyright theft not guilty of
stealing the basic structure of the
Marvin Gaye classic Let's Get It On
okay James uh thank you very much indeed